we're joined right now on the phone line
by uh the man who played
ghost in power for all those years and
now
is in the new film spell in select
theaters
starting today also available at home in
premium video on demand digital today
just in time for halloween weekend
the actor omari hardwick here on the
program how are you omari
how you doing i appreciate you having me
i'm so honored to be here
i'm i'm thrilled to have you here right
now are you typically in real life a
horror
movie guy i mean you normally take these
in
or you just like starring um not
i've never typically have been that guy
i mean you know having come from sports
as you know i come from
and maybe there's some horror thriller
to being an athlete
um it comes with a chair but never in
the genre of film
i've never necessarily been down with it
i get i i mean i get
i get the whole psychological thriller
yes i don't necessarily get down with
the blood and gore but
i've watched my share of the shining
children of the corn everyone probably
did a discerning thing to me and
i tend to like hannibal lecter i think
that anthony hopkins really got it in on
that one so
yeah of course which this film is being
compared to i've watched that as well
well there's a little bit of misery
uh to what's going on in your film as
well right omari i mean i don't know if
you
remember misery where uh james com was
locked in a house or locked in a room
but it seemed
like there's a little bit of that going
on right correct no you're right
it's in terms of the handcuffing in
terms of uh a woman enslaving a man
right and and sort of um being able to
have
her way with this man it's a little bit
like that in that sense but
this is different because of course
we're diving deep into the historical
component of
um voodoo the differentiation between
the two
how the appalachian area ironically
specifically around that
those virginia mountains how they're
still communities that get down with
that practitioners
people that work in uh and in kind of
like
grain and ground and mud and blood and
skin and use all of that to
sort of cut to create i guess or curate
this boogity doll and so
in that regard it's not what kathy bates
was doing with jimmy kahn yes
it's a little different but absolutely
i'm entrapped a lot like james khan
wasn't misery yeah
omari hardwick starring in spell again
just in time for
a halloween weekend here on the rich
eisen show let's uh dive a little bit
into that sports background um
you wound up on the georgia bulldogs
correct did you not back in the day
yep you are correct okay you know what's
funny is you
you were the university of michigan is
that correct i was at the university of
michigan uh from 86 to 90. so before you
were in the mid 90s with the georgia
bulldogs
yeah absolutely but ironically i only i
only bring that up to say my dream
school
actually which was to play for the maze
and blue
that was actually my i always my whole
life i thought i played for both shin
buckler and then it
transitioned into gary moller went to a
couple camps
roommated with terrell wheatley at one
of those camps and then uh
the offer from the big ten was actually
wisconsin northwestern as well but the
offer didn't come from
from michigan and i ended up at
university of georgia well that's a
great place to land but the fact that
you wanted to be wearing the maze and
blue just shows you about what a
successful smart man that you are
omari that uh i love that look at you
you know no i mean it just shows you
that you know
class you have taste um but
george is a great by the way backup plan
uh certainly if you want to play
football so so um in the defensive
backfield with you was in fact the
current coach
of the georgia bulldogs kirby smart is
that right
yeah he was there he was at the
epicenter of the defensive backfield um
playing none other than free safety uh
strong at times we both platoon
between strong um i as a corner to
strong safety and that he has a free
safety
to uh strong safety so he was doing it
up
of course there we had ray golf in that
transition to donand
who had martial had randy moss and then
they transitioned into coach rick
um who of course champ bailey and and
and the likes the ending years of robert
edwards and uh
and of course heinz ward had had those
same coaches as well so yeah kirby was
with me and now it's nice for all of us
to come back and hang out with our
fellow alum a little bit i bet so i'm
sure you're living and dying with
georgia bulldog football certainly the
last few years
i'm sure you are absolutely no i know
every time i talk to terrell davis
that's all he wants to talk about is
georgia bulldog football and i'm sure
you know seeing todd gurley balling out
for atlanta right now as he was last
night is particularly prideful for you
to watch
i imagine yeah no it's a good thing
because i'm i'm disappointed in the
falcons
in so many ways i'm really honestly i've
had this conversation recently with uh
travis stroud and a couple acting
buddies of mine who grew up in atlanta
travis trout haven't been a teammate at
georgia and we've talked about the fact
that i don't know maybe it's a
transplant city
sort of thing but it just doesn't seem i
brought it up to dion sanders as well
and i
said to prime and those other two
aforementioned cats that it just seems
like atlanta sports
uh georgia bulldogs included we just
don't seem to get over that hump
rich and it really it bothers a lot of
us particularly those that are native
and not transplants to the city um but
i'm proud of all of those guys like you
said
you know gurley getting it in tony
michelle at new england
that's right um i'm proud of all those
guys that you know represent
our city and the college i came from
very well i know
i know atlanta lost to the lions last
weekend at least deandre swift walked
out with a win
in atlanta you know i mean it seems like
he's getting better and stronger
every single week and heinz ward man i
mean
super bowl mvp i love that guy what was
it like being a college teammate of his
amari man it was it was like being
next to um you know when you you hear
that adage uh the last shall finish
first
rich and i'm sure you've heard it you
know whether being a person that was
raised in
any kind of religious thoughts or what
have you the adage of the last you'll
finish first is what it was like being
around them and what i mean by that is
sometimes bro you look over to the left
or to the right of the bench and he was
just sitting there
because they almost didn't know what to
do with him you know he's a football
player and it's often not the case that
people are drafted as such
he is an absolute player um play maker
you know what have you and so obviously
specifically becoming a wide receiver
not even not even with literally big
hands but obviously figuratively some of
the biggest hands the game's ever seen
and
we're going to pittsburgh and shows out
in ways that again at university of
georgia
sometimes we didn't know what to do with
them and we'd look over and you'd be
like why in highs in the game he'd go
into platoon at quarterback or maybe
third and four or whatever and
then he played receiver he kind of they
didn't you know put him in on the um
or on motion as a wing back but they
didn't really know what to do with them
all the time and i got to be honest and
we often as teammates
commented on that in our pride we beamed
in pride when
of course they figured out exactly what
to do with him in uh the great
city of pittsburgh it was awesome and i
think he should be our next inductee
to the hall of fame champ bayley and i
talked about it and i think he's going
to squeeze in the [ __ ]
so walk in you know what at some point
um i think he gets in um but the same
thing amari hardwick the actor uh from
power and now
spell which is in theaters select
theaters and uh on demand
and digital today on premium video at
home uh right here on the rich eisen
show
i i think the same thing you just
mentioned about what to do with him
is the same thing that's gonna keep him
from being in the hall sooner rather
than later
you know what i mean i got you you know
what i mean like in the fact that
okay we want to compare wide receiver
stats you know
randy moss just got in and so on and so
forth
but if you put it all together like if
you want to talk about a football player
like him uh who else somebody like brian
dawkins
um those are the guys that can play like
if i want to build a team
of football players who you need your
head on a swivel because somebody's
going to come for you
um that's right is another one you know
i mean although
he's you know he's a first ballot guy
but i'm talking about
football players he is
one of them there's no two ways about it
no two ways about it
i would throw i think you nailed it i
think you know as often obviously with
your
savvy uh brain within the sport realm of
course you know that rich but also i
would include in that ed reed
oh yeah i mean like ed reed from
baltimore he's in that category too
oh yeah and i do agree and and i guess i
haven't thought about it from that
standpoint that
perhaps the same things that were his
gifts at university of georgia and
that being such a multitude of no cat um
in the football realm
he kind of was just sitting there at
times coaches not knowing what to do
with him that the equally that's been
his curse
as it pertains to post pittsburgh the
accolades that'll come or not come i
think that's a great assessment
so just one last for you on this so
terrell davis was right before you and
champ was right after or did you cross
paths with either of these hall of
famers
both of them both of them and both of
them are not only having been
uh very close to me not only crossing
paths but having been very very close to
me they
they both are probably my two closest
friends from uh those years robert
edwards included
travis trout included um but absolutely
terrell
and chad bailey are probably the ones
that i talk to the most good people man
all of them
and then uh you know congrats on being
able to transition as well as you have
it's not easy
it's not easy that's the question so
many football players have is what next
and you got thrown into that when you
were undrafted and
you know power and now you're starring
in this movie spell
i mean it's it's really great you're
you're you're uh you're successful and
you deserve it
i appreciate that man it's super
humbling i kind of kind of looked at it
from the standpoint of um
of knowing very early rich that it was a
misnomer and not
calling um an athlete an artist
you know they often don't get called
artists whether it's the balletic
prowess of a basketball player you know
lebron to back to michael over to kobe
rest in power
and rest in peace or if it's just a
power as my wife often says of
to her the the biggest and best athlete
is a football player and she says it's
not necessarily from a skill standpoint
but often when she's looking at
linebackers the better parts of 260
running a 4-6 you know 40 hunt hun
hawking down a running back or hunting
down a quarterback
that's a different level of artistry and
we're not called that and so the
transition was interesting when people
kind of wanted to talk about the two the
amalgamation of which might be just that
in the actor that you see in me maybe
whatever you see or whatever
colleagues competing for me or against
me for a role maybe they
are going against an athlete meets meets
this guy that's figured out craft try it
sean springs back in the day used to ask
me about it charles woodson
yes would ask me about it there's some
you know emmanuel sanders he's often
tried to pick my brain kyrie irving who
i big brother a lot he's
he's another one from the from the
basketball side who said
hey man you think i can really play in
this world you know after this time of
being a coach
i mean yeah he's he's got some chops
kyrie's got some as uncle drew he's got
some chops there's no doubt about that
he definitely he definitely has it you
know obviously carrie cruz
he's on that guy but the compliment that
you that you paid in me rich i i don't
take it with a grain of salt i take it
i'm very humble because
i don't look like dwayne johnson or or
terry crews i look like the guy next
door
you know what i mean i don't look like
okay there's always time omari there's
time
there's time there's weights there's the
weight room there's still always that or
you know
and and thomas jones thomas jones is
doing it right now too i love thomas
he's doing it right now too thomas jones
is doing
and we can't forget of course we cannot
forget uh michael strahan and all he's
transitioned into
and all he's become even if it's not
from the chesapeake standpoint
if it's you know the true gift of acting
he definitely showed all those other
gifts that god put up himself
and then uh last one um you know i don't
mean to correct you uh
you mentioned prime it's it's not prime
it's coach prime um
omari coach he's
coach prime time now he's coach which is
awesome
it's great it's great and and and you
know who's gonna uh
rue the and i'll i'll say this even
though i he probably wouldn't want me to
florida state's going to rue that
mistake
for the moment well maybe they'll maybe
they'll revisit that maybe they'll
revisit that yeah
i think so i think they will revisit i
think it's a good staircase
um we actually share ironically a
manager and
uh prime and our coach fryer sorry about
that rich coach frank it's all good
sorry primetime
and uh and sharing that that um you're
talking about constance
is that who you're talking about yeah
yeah and constance said it best i'm glad
you gave her a shout out because
yes come on now what you just said rich
she was like hey
i gotta be honest they will all figure
it out and
even if it's not his alma mater other
schools will try to get their hands on
them but she stated it being a good
staircase
and a good trampoline of sorts for him
to springboard off of into this coaching
world i think he's going to be excellent
i think obviously he's one of the top 10
athletes to ever grace to earth
um obviously specifically coming from
the world of football but
i think he's got a lot to impart on
young kids not just from a
coaching standpoint but just betterment
of them as young men as
they go to that next chapter of their
life so i think he's dialing in
and and you forgot somebody i got to
correct you okay okay you forgot to
state that
in this world that i was able to
transition into yes
you yourself brothers no stranger to
movies you don't like three or four
movies right well you know amari i get
i get uh i get the uh odd residual check
for
playing uh tv guy in uh csi miami
um you know like mike if you want to go
old school
um you know sure i go to school with you
you do your things yeah i appreciate it
yeah me me and me and
me and lil bow wow were in the same
movie um
i just say that with no hint of irony
that's fact these are facts that cannot
be disputed
uh omari and you try to hide from them
and now the world knows that you can
check out rich eisen on spell part two
which will come out
i don't know three years from now i'm
all in congrats on spell one
um we know a lot of the same people
omari let's make this uh make this a
regular thing thanks for the call
everybody should check out spell and
select theaters available at home on
premium video on demand and digital
today
thanks for the call you take care of
yourself super humble big fan of yours
you take care right back at you that's
omari hardwick
omari hardwick on twitter and at omari
hardwick official on instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here